we are back with this Fox News Alert Kim
jong-eun is in grave danger reports this
morning
the North Korean leader is in critical
condition after heart surgery rumors
have been swirling about the North
Korean dictator's health ever since he
had a procedure and after he missed this
celebration for his grandfather's
birthday last week
now those rumors are reportedly on the
radar of US intelligence agencies brain
all right he was last seen at a meeting
ten days ago
South Korea's government pushing back
saying it has not seen anything unusual
out of the North fox sources say the
White House is aware of the reports but
can't confirm his condition let's see if
we get the the answer from Robert
O'Brien National Security Advisor Robert
great to see you let me ask you what
could you tell us about Kim jong-un
I do believe South Korea there is no
problem or the rest of the world that
there is well we're monitoring these
reports very closely and as you know
North Korea is a very closed society
there's not a Free Press there they're
parsimonious with the information that
they provide about many things including
the health of vacum Jenna and so we're
monitoring those developments closely
people should know that we have a great
intelligence community we the president
the vice-president secretary Pompeo
secretary Esper general Milley we've got
a lot of Watchmen on the towers during
this coronavirus crisis making sure that
America is safe whether it's from the
virus or from adversaries abroad so
we're keeping a close eye on
developments in North Korea as we are in
other parts of the world ambassador
could you tell us why the president
decided to sign this executive order he
says he's going to to temporarily
suspend immigration look we're trying to
do everything the president's trying to
do everything you can to put the health
of the American people first or in this
crisis and so this is one step it's it's
not dissimilar to the the restrictions
on travel from China that he implemented
back on January 29th at the very outset
of this public health crisis we think
that that those restrictions save
thousands or tens of thousands of
American lives they were criticized by
some at the time
one candidate Vice President Biden said
that it was xenophobic Nancy Pelosi
introduced a bill to ban the bans but
the president's not going to be guided
by politics here he's gonna be by guided
by the hell and what doing what's best
for the health of the American people
I'm sure an ambassador of course this is
just as the banner says below us it is a
temporary suspension of immigration and
we know that federal statute does give
him the authority in cases of public
health and things like that it although
it is unprecedented
back in the 1918 pandemic with the flu I
think the United States states still
allowed in 100,000 people so I we get
the part about how it's trying to stem
the tide of incoming infections but at
the same time the president in his tweet
ambassador made it clear that this is
also about safeguarding American jobs
because there are so many people out of
work right now and they need jobs well
this this virus came to our shores from
overseas sadly and not only has it
affected the health and and caused the
death of many Americans and our hearts
and prayers go out to those about family
members who are sick or struggling
who've lost loved ones and also gosh
these I was watching the interview that
you did with Liam raising money to help
our first responders those are real
heroes the doctors and nurses the
custodial staff that these hospitals on
the front line keeping the hospital's
clean and free from infection they're
doing a great job but there's been an
economic cost here too and and the
president's looking out for Americans on
both fronts that at every turn so
obviously there's a big push to find out
what China knew and why we still don't
know everything about it president's
saying we need to get in there and look
around and find out where this all
started where there was a Wuhan Lab or
whether it was actually in a wet market
which mysteriously has reopened when the
president complimented the president of
China early was it because he was under
a under the illusion that he was getting
all accurate and full and the full
story about this virus and does he
regret those compliments to he through
it
President Xi no look the president's
always very complimentary and his
dealings with foreign leaders if the
American people could be on the phone
calls that he has with our adversaries
and our friends he's a real gentleman it
was the same way with President Xi but
he's been clear from the outset we need
to get the CDC into China there's really
a huge burden on China to tell us where
this came from did it come from a lab
did it come from a wet market neither of
those are good answers right I mean
these wet markets are but Robert it's a
plagues Robert don't you believe it it's
not it's not something that they're
obligated to do and they still haven't
done it
and I'm just wondering when are we gonna
get punitive with them and why we just
continue to put the anatta analyst hat
on and we don't get more aggressive with
them to come clean once and for all
well I think we're being pretty tough on
China and look there are lawsuits that
have been filed by folks out there some
countries are looking at how to deal
with with China going forward we
certainly are but remember this is the
fourth or fifth plague that's come out
of China since 2000 we've had the avian
flu
we Unser's we had h1n1 and so whether
these are coming out of labs that have
sloppy procedures whether they're coming
out of the wet markets that are really
horrific if you watch some of those
things we've got to stop this I mean we
got to stop the export of these viruses
from China we're going to make our
position we have made our position on
these issues very clear to the Chinese I
think it's becoming a worldwide call now
that China has to come forward with the
information I mean if you take a look at
and how they've handled the virus with
whistleblowers disappearing and new some
news men from and women from the Wall
Street Journal and New York Times being
kicked out of the country and you can't
Rast that to how Taiwan or Singapore or
other countries have handled this there
there's just a real big disparity there
and we've got to get to the bottom of
what happened
yeah ambassador how do we do that how do
we hold China accountable when they're
covering things up they're getting rid
of the whistleblowers you know we're not
going to ever be able to get in that lab
they're not gonna let us in there to
find out what happened if it really did
start there how do you do this how do
you investigate China well we have a lot
of tools in our toolkit but one of the
I know I think there are Americans that
are I understand their lawsuits that are
being filed here against China we'll see
we'll see how it all plays out but but
with some of these trial lawyers there
they're pretty dogged and the Chinese
have a lot of assets around the world
you know we'll see what happens but
right now what we're doing is calling on
the Chinese to cooperate and and we want
to get along with China we have a trade
deal we'd like to get along with China
but China needs to behave in a fashion
that makes them a responsible player in
the world and and unfortunately with the
outset of this virus it wasn't great and
they've got to fix that
all right ambassador Robert O'Brien it's
got a great up edie the pages of the
Wall Street Journal check it out if you
get the paper or online sir thank you
very much for joining us from the North
Lawn looks like a nice day thank you
beautiful
thank you